we're still months away from the
football season of course but after next
year's Superbowl there will be more
football to be played last month a new
spring league called the Alliance of
American football was announced its
inaugural season kicks off February 9th
2019 a week after the Super Bowl teams
in eight different cities will play a 10
game season the games will be seen on a
free streaming app as well as right here
on CBS and CBS Sports Network this
morning we're joined by the Alliance's
co-founder and CEO Charlie ever saw and
14-year NFL veteran and Super Bowl MVP
Hines Ward who's serving as an executive
of player relations welcome to you both
and congratulations thank you very much
so Charlie tell us how is this different
from the NFL and what's in it for the
fans well I think the biggest thing is
that we brought in the best players and
the best coaches to be at the top of the
organization we wanted to give fans not
just an opportunity to see great
football but to see what would happen if
you brought the players and the league
together because the idea of the
Alliance his name was bringing fans
players in the game together we came on
this morning though for two reasons one
obviously CBS being our partner we
wanted to do this here we're going to
start rolling our cities out this week
and we wanted to announce today here
that our first city will be Orlando now
we didn't think that just going to a
city was enough of announcement because
this is Saturday morning on CBS so we
thought that to additionally make this
more meaningful we would also announce
our first head coach you got a big name
here we have someone and listen this is
the thing what when we set out what we
wanted to do is show that we could put
the best people on the field both on on
both sides of the line I guess I should
say so a seven-time SEC champion a
Heisman Trophy winner and a national
champion head coach there is Steve
Spurrier will be the first head coach of
the week I've never seen it without a
visor
[Laughter]
thank you good to be here was it drew
you to coming back into football because
she left the game and I'm guessing
enjoying retirement alone I got a call
from JK McKay and he started explaining
the Alliance and the new rules I really
like two and a half hour games thirty
seconds in between plays and so forth
and the fans want to see that yeah and
really you know in life we all need a
challenge and unfortunately my
universities got me as a consultant
ambassador in Florida I really
appreciate that but this is chance to
get a bunch of guys to coach compete and
try to win the championship heck there's
gonna be a winner in April and whoever
does he's gonna do some celebrations
you've coached you've been around other
football startups in the past coaching
in the USFL right what do you need to do
to attract fans well first of all we got
to have a good team and to be
competitive and make the game
interesting and like the two and a half
hour rule that we hope to get to and of
course you got to win too we all know
that you can't lose a lot so of course
we're gonna throw the ball gonna try to
score points
you know Heinz I know that people want
to see good football but certainly in
the NFL player safety has come up a lot
is that going to be something that you
guys focus on well what their lines I
mean player safety that's top priority I
mean that's something we want to bring
to our league but you know you know for
me being on the player side of it's all
about the well-being of the players I
mean we have guys like Troy Polamalu
Justin Tuck Jared Allen I mean we want
to be the bridge and kind of the voice
for the players so not only just help
them while they're playing but also
helping them when their careers are over
I mean we're off the field we're setting
up scholarships for players and also
having some financial internships and
and really get them financial counseling
for guys to understand what your career
is done playing now they're able to have
the knowledge to be able to take care of
their money and that's what I'm excited
about the league of course protecting
the players are on the field with the
change nope kickoffs right no kickoffs
yes you're getting rid of the foot and
football a little bit a little bit well
I think to a large degree what we looked
at was what what makes the game the most
fun for the fans and what makes it the
safest for the players and so you look
at the least popular play by almost
every study that's ever been done on the
NFL the kickoff is the least popular
play so why do we still have it yeah and
so if you can come up with a creative
way and I think Bill and JK come up with
an incredibly interesting way to deal
with the onside kick which is that we
give the piece if you want to go for an
onside kick instead of having to do the
hands team everything we give you the
ball in your own 35 facing fourth and 10
if you can convert you get to keep the
ball and go if you don't the other team
gets the ball basically knocking on the
door the red let me just add to that
have you never been on an onside kick of
the front line no I've been on the front
line for the kickoff so eliminating that
it only provides protection for the
players in Arlen
Charlie you're dead Dick Ebersol
launched the XFL with Vince McMahon back
in 2001 that League only lasted a year
so I mean did you look at that to sort
of study what you might do here well I
looked at all of the spring leagues I
mean one of the reasons that JK and Bill
and Steve and as you'll see the coaches
that were rolling out one of these we
looked at was what had really worked in
that area because football is the only
sport in the world that just ends right
you if you like soccer you can watch
soccer year-round you're like auto
racing you can watch it year-round
basketball baseball you can't do that
with football so and the USFL drew huge
crowds the XFL drew huge crowds in 2001
they were averaging like 25,000 tickets
a game so what we looked at was okay
what worked about that one didn't the
number one thing that didn't work was
quality football you got to put quality
football football has to be the focus
and so bringing guys like Heinz and Troy
and Jared and Justin but also really
putting coaches on the field who are
born champions I mean this is a
ridiculous example prophy winner and a
champion but you'll see that our focus
from now until February 9th you'll see a
ridiculous laser focus on the quality of
the game and Steve along those lines you
know you've got guys who do not make the
NFL but still have great ability is this
something that we're gonna see in this
league and maybe they
make their way you know Dan it's a fine
line but I'm who makes the team and who
doesn't and NFL and we don't have a
minor league of professional football
baseball has minor leagues basketball
you can play in Europe or the Oh CBA and
so forth so those those players get a
chance to continue playing even if they
don't play to highest level and then
maybe someday they play well enough to
go the highest level so if a player is
in our lights and he gets to go to the
NFL we're gonna shake his hand and say
good going and because he can make a lot
more money in the NFL certainly all
right Charlie over salt Hines Ward coach
Spurrier congratulations I need a gig
thank you and thanks for being here and
good luck with the league